hey youtubers is Charlie so awesome news
Brian singer confirmed that mr. sinister
is going to be the villain of the next
Wolverine movie someone explained how
he's a really good way to sew up
Deadpool and cable along with the Dark
Phoenix like the Phoenix saga arc that
they're getting ready to do in the
movies
so it's all connected most of you have
probably heard by now that Brian singer
confirmed the post-credits scene from
x-men apocalypse on the commentary where
he said mister sinister who was named
dropped as the Essex corporation isn't
Nathaniel Essex the true name of mr.
sinister would be appearing in the next
Wolverine movie now we're all just
calling it Wolverine 3 but they're
really doing an old man Logan type thing
where it's an older version of Wolverine
later in the timeline Patrick Stewart
cameos so you can imagine how much later
in the timeline it is I don't know how
close they'll stick to old man Logan in
the comics but it was a dark dark story
Logan because of his X gene abilities
like his natural abilities to heal
tissue he just out lives everyone mr.
sinister is another one of those types
of people who can regenerate himself he
can regenerate himself from a single
drop of blood so his abilities are even
more powerful than Wolverines so it
makes sense that in the distant future
if somebody hadn't vaporized him mr.
sinister would still be around but the
really cool thing back to that
post-credit scene so what happened the
Essex corporation stole samples of
Wolverines blood in one of them said 23
on it X 23 is a clone of Wolverine a
female clone of Wolverine who becomes
the new Wolverine in the comics Marvel
did some really crazy stuff with the
Wolverine character they killed him off
then they brought him back the current
version of Logan in the comics is the
old man Logan character who exists
simultaneously with the young version of
Wolverine who's fighting with the
Avengers
so getting meta for a second Hugh
Jackman has been playing Wolverine now
for almost 20 years and most of that
time has been spent shirtless so he's
just basically said that he's getting
really tired he would like to transition
away from the role eventually so this is
his final Wolverine movie final solo
movie not final appearances Wolverine
just finals
so I think that he'll appear in the next
x-men movie but what they might try to
do instead of just recasting a version
of Logan they might try to introduce the
x-23 character she'll take the
day-to-day role with the x-men and like
the big team-up x-men movies and then if
they want to do another Wolverine solo
film they could always do a Wolverine
team-up film where old man Logan teams
up with young female Logan they have a
relatively decent relationship in the
comics they've been times when they butt
heads you have to remember that she is a
clone of Logan so she gets a lot of his
personality traits but they've tried to
have a little bit of fun with the way
they write her in the comics right now
so if you read the current Marvel comics
right now you'll get a taste for what
she's like she's pretty fun but in the
movies like the big surprise is that I
kind of thought that mr. sinister would
be the big villain of the next x-men
movie because it seems like they're
transitioning into a Dark Phoenix arc
which i think is a pretty safe bet for
them you develop the Jean Grey character
you just spread that over the course of
the next couple movies like you don't
want to blow your Phoenix wad into one
single movie that could be Fox's x-men
version of infinity war doing like the
Dark Phoenix arc where she fully becomes
the Phoenix in the final film but they
were gonna do that it'd be way down the
road what about Deadpool though Deadpool
had so much Hugh Jackman in his movie
without actually having Hugh Jackman in
it it was hilarious
now Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman are
really great friends in real life in
their both Fox properties so it was
really easy for them to do that stuff in
that Deadpool movie
I think the Wolverine movie is going to
be way more serious so I don't know how
much of Deadpool we'd see in it but
there might be like a few nods to
Deadpool they might use Deadpool to
promote the movie but we're talking
about characters that are super
long-lived just because they regenerate
their tissue Deadpool is one of the
other big characters of the Marvel
Universe that just regenerates himself
instantly but aside from old man Logan
mr. sinister stuff we don't know too
much about what's going to happen in the
movie presumably it'll be a nice bookend
for the Wolverine character but make no
mistake as long as Hugh Jackman has a
good relationship with the people at box
with Bryan Singer and his team of the
other actors he will probably always
come back for little bits is just that
The Wolverine
character won't be a really huge deal if
he transitions away and they don't
introduce x-23 so let me know in the
comments if you Jackman is not going to
be Wolverine anymore in the x-men movies
do you think they're going to try and
transition to x-23 with that x-23 mr.
sinister post-credit scene from
Apocalypse but if you don't know a lot
about mr. sinister he's basically like a
geneticist in the Marvel Universe that's
kind of what he does like he's just
obsessed with perfection so eventually
like there are a couple storylines where
he just completely clones himself into
the Marvel Universe it's like one of
those Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
stories where it kind of exists off by
itself like it's not canon to the main
series but for a long time in the comics
like a big part of the backbone of his
backstory is being obsessed with Scott
Summers bloodline with Cyclops his
bloodline like he first showed up in
1891 in cross paths with Scott Summers
ancestor Daniel Somers then runs afoul
of apocalypse gets changed into his mr.
sinister form that you see today that
came as a result of his encounter with
apocalypse and then let you know later
obviously there's a lot of x-factor a
lot of stuff in the 90s that happen with
apocalypse in the x-men mr. sinister is
there through it all and even in the
continuity of the x-men films he was a
Nazi briefly like he just shows up
through history at all these big
conflicts so wouldn't be too hard for
them to retcon him into the backstory of
the x-men films but obviously the comics
get way more complicated there's way
more story there for mr. sinister than
they could ever do in the movies so I
think that they'll just pick and choose
things where one he's trying to clone
Wolverine because that actually did
happen in the comics and then he hears
about Jean Grey learns about the Phoenix
force so that in later movies if he
shows up in the main x-men movies he
could be more obsessed with that stuff
so it's all about breeding bloodlines
certain traits in and out with him so he
experiments a lot with people throughout
the ages really I don't know how they're
going to work mr. sinister into
apocalypse his backstory in the movies
so they might have to sidestep some of
that but in the comics one of the
reasons why he's so obsessed with Scott
Summers is because he believes that he
will give birth like he'll lead to
a mutant powerful enough to destroy
apocalypse who he then later discovers
is Nathaniel Summers aka cable so
already the wheels in your mind are
turning and you're like oh wait this
might be a way to crossover with the
Deadpool sequel because they're doing
cable in Deadpool too so you see how
it's all connected
but the Deadpool movie exists in this
really like questionable timeframe
they've kind of tried to keep it as its
separate thing but they might weave it
in later on like Bryan Singer was saying
the tone of Deadpool makes it really
hard to cross over but it is connected
to the x-men films mr. sinister is just
a really easy way to tie that all up
together so you guys can let me know
like do you feel like they're going to
turn mr. sinister into a much bigger
thing in the x-men continuity I feel
like they have to but it'll start off
with this Wolverine movie in just a
heads up to that movie's dropping in
March so I'm expecting the first trailer
to drop in the next couple of months we
should actually see it pretty soon if
you didn't know they've already shot the
Wolverine movie I get hype for mr.
sinister get hyped for X 23 things but
was probably happen next is I'm going to
do a Punisher Season 1 video they just
announced the first villain like the
first big villain that they've cast but
they won't be shooting that till early
next year so just expect to hear about
them casting more characters throughout
the rest of this year as they burrow
through Luke Cage iron fist stuff and we
actually might get some more iron fist
footage at New York Comic Con which is
like the first weekend in October so
lots of really cool Marvel stuff coming
up real soon why you guys wait for
that's a post you can click here for new
Luke Cage that just dropped you can
click here for Iron Man for Marvel hype
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight